vous dites que vous refusez qu'on vous
appelle journalistes pourquoi alors
petite nuance à ça commence bien parce
que tout est question de nuance bah oui
c'est pas une question de hiérarchie
entre c'est bien c'est pas bien c'est
que moi je ne fais pas de news art news
je vais sur le terrain je fais des
documentaires comme paul moreira il
s'appelle documentariste mon travail
c'est de faire des documentaires
ces différentes du travail de
journaliste pour vous les journalistes
journalistes qui couvrent cette bien ils
font de la désinformation ou il nous à
nous tous il ya un mec génial que alors
voilà il y en avait un non non il ya de
la pac un méga renaud girard par exemple
qui sait très bien exprimer ce qui
couvre en ce moment depuis que je suis
rentré et je vais être très honnête avec
vous que j'atteins monte lema ma télé
parce que non pas parce que je voulais
pas voir les news parce que quand on
rentre de trois semaines de
bombardements content l'aurait vu des
corps déchiquetés de partout du sang ça
pue c'est violent on s'est fait tirer
dessus on est menacée de mort à un
moment donné vous savez on a juste
besoin de silence juste de silence est
conscient de tenir le clip habilités de
quitter les gens assuré moi je dors pas
beaucoup jeudi à théo lajudie en ce
moment on dort peu un compte orange de
la semaine et je pense que seriez vous
le savez n'en sort pas indemne d'un
conflit et je pense que tous ceux qui le
couvrent c'est la même chose donc c'est
cette raison pour laquelle j'ai atteint
ma télé c'est que le bruit me
sensibilise un peu les oreilles alors en
2014 des séparatistes pro russes avec la
même indépendance du dombass territoire
ukrainien où les habitants sont
majoritairement russophone depuis
l'armée ukrainienne ni les séparatistes
se font la guerre où vous étiez au
donbass vous y êtes allé combien de fois
trois fois trois fois d'accord si je
peux me permettre parce que là j'ai vu
encore qu'il resterait peut-on j'ai
simplement vous demandez pour une fois
cyril un service je suis à riom meilleur
je n'ai pas pu m'exprimer j'aimerais
parce que je vois que le temps court
simplement pouvoir m'exprimer sur
certaines choses que je n'ai pas pu dire
les dire maintenant et après je réponds
à toutes vos questions comme je les dis
ailleurs à votre équipe à l'organisme
merci beaucoup simplement avant de
commencer sur ce sur ce conflit qui est
un des wass c'est une boucherie et
jamais je ne cautionnerai de guerre je
ne les ai pas cautionner dans le
haut-karabagh je ne les ai pas
cautionner nulle part ni au yémen nulle
part mais pour comprendre ce conflit
juste sergei j'aimerais revenir là
dessus parce que j'ai écouté une de vos
interviews sur avec un avec un jeune là
où j'ai pas tout compris ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est juste ce que j'aimerais
place et pourquoi dès 2014 il ya quand
même eu des bugs des bugs et tout ce que
je veux dire des bugs le 2 décembre 2004
mais des ingérences russe et américaine
vous l'avez dit dans la zone qui a été
bombardée depuis huit ans donetsk est
lougansk y avait des russes mais il y
avait aussi des américains et j'en ai
les preuves j'aimerais juste faits
énoncés
nouveau call nos confrères en ont parlé
ils n'ont pas été relayé cette ce
travail d' enquête avait été fait au
préalable donc je reprends le 2 décembre
2014 nathalie jarosz co ressortissante
américaine au poste de ministre des
finances de l'ukraine
l'ukraine lui accorder la nationalité
ukrainienne le jour de son investiture
peu de bleu l'ukraine a bénéficié de
l'aimable assistance du gouvernement
américain à travers la visite en ukraine
du directeur de la cia en avril 2014
john brennan tout ça je vous invite à
l'oeuf à checker il ya eu donc le
problème de l'ukraine monsieur sergei
c'est que les états-unis la russie y
sont depuis le début et l'otan est
également on sait qu'il ya eu des
entraînements depuis 2014 d'instructeurs
russe je suis pas là pour prendre le
parti des russes je ne suis pas anti
ukraine ou pro russe ou hantise et les
skis ou entier ou anti russe je suis
simplement là pour équilibrer ce débat
parce qu'il nous l'a en train de nous
mener dans une boucherie une boucherie
terrible la guerre c'est affreux quand
vous la vivez quand vous voyez des corps
déchiquetés mais toute l'ukraine est
déchiqueté on se doit de dire quand même
que les responsables c'est pas les
civils parce que c'est eux qu'en font
les frais
cc gouvernement la ccl gouvernement l'a
hélé et les états unis n'ont pas été
fair play est ce que vous trouvez normal
est ce qu'on peut imaginer ne serait ce
qu'une seconde que l'élysée nomme un an
et demi un administrateur américain à la
tête de bercy est ce que ce serait
possible
pdg d'investissement privé donc qu'est
ce que vous êtes en train de dire alors
j'ai construit sa américaine voilà
simplement est-ce que c'est quand même
je pense qu'on s'est clairement quelle
est la cause pour vous quelle est la
cause de cette guerre leur dis que je
pense que ce sont des enjeux
géopolitiques
énergétique ensuite l'ukraine est très
mal placé elle est c'est une zone tampon
entre entre entre le continent euro
asiatique et l'europe est aujourd'hui
j'ai le sentiment mais ces propos
n'engagent que moi qu'on est en train
d'assister à un bras de fer entre de
nouvelles alliances qui sont
particulièrement inquiétantes russie
chine inde
europe occident et que ça peut très mal
terminé je ne pense pas que l'on fasse
la guerre
par charité malheureusement et j'en suis
navré pour les victimes parce que je le
sais parce que je les filme les éviers
les victimes je les ai filmé donc
nombreux pays il ya quelques mois
j'étais j'étais dans le haut karabagh et
je peux vous dire que ça a été d'une
sauvagerie j'en dors pas encore on
voyait des gens se faire égorger les
dents vous ne dormez pas cyril croyez
moi vous ne dormez pas
alors donc ce que je veux dire par là
c'est que
il se passe des choses qui dépassent qui
dépasse le simple simplement la guerre
il ya d'autres enjeux derrière il ya
d'autres enjeux et là on est plongé dans
un dans un conflit avec un suivisme
américain depuis 2014 qui me semble pas
très net pas très net et que je regrette
qu'on n'ait pas un villepin de 2003 qui
disent oui c'est inacceptable ce qui se
passe mais est-ce qu'on peut pas trouver
d'autres moyens pour pour pour stopper
ce conflit est ce que les apports de
mandy moore et puis huit ans aurait pu
peut-être nous éviter ce carnage a
normalement on la verra avant-hier par
les ministres wagner ouais ça quand
comment comme vous pouvez expliquer ça
alors comment je l'expliqué c'est très
simple je discute beaucoup avec déjà mes
sources sont toujours deux généraux
français parce que et d'ailleurs les
pièces que je vous ai envoyé voyez bien
que c'est des sourds soit américaine ou
des ong je n'en vois rien de russin
d'accord vous êtes d'accord oui merci
comment je peux expliquer un le temps
d'une enquête pendant une zone de guerre
sergei c'est très long c'est très long
on ne sait pas ce qui s'est passé
monsieur gomart l'ancien directeur de la
direction d'humilite deux françaises
deux militaires mais a expliqué que pour
la bosnie retrouvez les crimes de guerre
ça a pris plus de 6 ans donc pour
l'instant je dis prudence attention
attention à ces médias de deux fruits
vous savez je vais vous dire
moi je vous dis attention parce qu'on va
droit dans le mur une petite parenthèse
sur les mises à venir il ya aussi un
massacre au mahdi la
même jour trois jours chan et j'aurais
aimé qu'on en parle un petit peu plus
également sur les médias mesure c'est
parce que et il ya vraiment il ya
beaucoup de civils tous été massacrés au
mali et je pense qu'il faut falloir
aussi il va falloir aussi bouger assez
rapidement pour le mali parce que ça
devient très très inquiétant et c'est
vrai qu'on en parle moins que le crâne
on va pas dire et on va pas faire une
guerre voilà de ski médiatique contre
l'ukraine mais il faut parler du ne
permet dé sa mort et il n'y a pas de
hiérarchie dans l'art exactement on va
parler de tout mais mais il faut aussi
parler aussi parce que c'est important
voilà je vous dis donc sergei camp quand
on entend ce que dit anne-laure
voilà qui dit que
parce que vous vous reprocher c'est que
vous dites que
voilà les médias européens disent que la
russie a tous les torts pour vous on n'a
pas tous les torts que ceux qui nous
regardent et ce que je viens de vous
dire en fait les torts sont partagés ce
que je reproche aux maîtres les
américains et les russes et ça en fait
les enseignants eux mêmes et aussi les
ukrainiens sur les accords de myst n'ont
pas été respectées je vous ai envoyé des
vidéos je rappelle tout de même que bien
qu'ils aient eu une influence russe à
donetsk est lougansk un président qui à
travers des hélicoptères de combat
tir à bout portant sur sa population
c'est un crime de guerre et je me fais
appeler les renseignements français donc
pour auchan qu en 2014 c'est un crime de
guerre il y a eu je ne vous avez vu les
corps sont déchiquetés le septième elle
parle encore à l'appui ses jambes
vous avez vu ces images
est ce que c'est normal je ne défend
personne je suis la première à dire que
les russes ont une responsabilité
je viens d'ouvrir avec ça c'est bien
vous le disais ce soir il se l'est dit
et je les dis d'ailleurs si les gens
avaient bien fait leur boulot je parle
de libération merci libération
d'ailleurs je vous annonce que je les
attaque en diffamation soit dit en
passant parce que tout ce qu'ils ont dit
est faux tout tout tout
sachez que si vous lisez les articles
que j'ai mis sur sur twitter j'ai accusé
également l'ukraine d'être corrompu mais
même ianoukovitch j'ai jamais pris la
défense alors je mets ça n'a jamais été
repris dans terre il ya surtout si on
avait tout fait pour pour pour
discréditer mes propos et pour que ce
que j'ai fait qui est neutre
soit soit sourd à passer sous silence
sachez simplement une dernière chose en
2015 sargueil je suis parti avec un
ukrainien d'origine française
ce dossier vous demander si vous
concerne et non ils vous concerne pas
jamais je n'oserais vous faire ça
j'ai encore un peu de déontologie mais
vous savez la personne qui m'a
accompagné et ça ne regarde pas
l'armée française n'est pas impliqué
mais c'est pour répondre aux accusations
de benoît de victimes qui disaient oui
cette jeune femme a dû être
enrôlé par les milices russe bah c'est
ce qu'on a entendu alors voilà eh bien
regardez avec qui je suis participation
de sergei plaindre je suis parti avec un
ancien légionnaire delà de la vision
française ok donc je pense qu'en termes
de renseignements l'armée française elle
sait bien faire son boulot ok alors vous
pouvez tourner vous pouvez être chic et
je sens mais s'il vous plaît on n'est
pas là pour faire votre procès non c'est
un procès mais c'est normal que non non
je m'en donner que non mais ce qui est
clair ok bien sûr vous n'êtes ni masque
éclairé vite qui n'a pas cessé de dire
que j'avais été manipulé mais c'est faux
nous venons mais excusez moi ah non là
là on n'est pas sur les réseaux sociaux
sur les réseaux sociaux sur libération
c'est très sympa libération des réseaux
sociaux mais là on est à une heure de
grande écoute où il ya énormément plus
de gens ils sont au courant de tout ce
que vous dites il ya très peu de gens
qui lisent libération il ya beaucoup de
gens qui la touche pas à mon pote
énormément de gens qui sont alors
voilà parce que j'aimerais jouer
beaucoup mais là votre cas perso
personne ne le comprend enfin voilà
c'est bien que vous ayez voilà préciser
vos positions comme ça au moins ce sera
fait et c'est bien que vous l'ayez fait
ici sergei sur ce qu'a dit anne-laure
déjà
à la limite si vous auriez dû ceux ci
vous auriez si vous aviez dit ça depuis
huit ans on serait peut-être pas là en
train d'étudier votre votre votre
histoire parce qu'en fait c'est
absolument pas clair ce que j'ai regardé
on fait dans les eaux dans vos
publications en fait clairement ou dit
vous êtes pro russe vous êtes manipulés
par les russes vous travaillez que du
côté russe vous accusez les ukrainiens
vous avez mis vous avez parlé de 13
mille morts pendant le conflit et vous
avez présenté ça comme les treize mille
morts produit par les ukrainiens tandis
que c'est les deux camps est beaucoup
plus vite vous coupez oui je n'ai jamais
dit ça y est la preuve en est invite
tous les sets où les internautes à
regarder ma chimio des commencé
plusieurs blessures sur les rues de brut
et moi s'il vous plaît oui j'ai léger
enregistrer les conversations avec le
journal libération le monde et je leur
ai dit tout ce que vous dites et ils ont
écrit des papiers qui ont contredit tout
ce que j'ai dit c'est pour ça que
j'attaque en diffamation réécouter les
six effet nous fassions c'est un comble
on veut parler la situation ici en
russie et vous voulez avoir votre point
de vue là on n'est pas là pour dire
zélés pour user n'est pas pour eux voilà
on veut savoir ce qui se passe et telle
est votre regard alors rural dit alors
alors d'abord c'est passionnant de vous
écouter effectivement quand on regarde
le travail on comprend que vous puissiez
plus dormir parce qu'effectivement moi
j'ai on a vu sur votre documentaire dans
le haut karabakh et effectivement c'est
complètement traumatisant il faut que
tout le monde le voit pas ce qu'est
visait effectivement c'est l'horreur de
la guerre bon une fois qu'on a dit ça
moi je vous écoute ok très bien le
conflit la géopolitique les
responsabilités des uns et des autres au
aujourd'hui concrètement
concrètement il ya la russie qui envahi
l'ukraine il ya quatre millions de
réfugiés il ya des charniers des
exactions des scènes horribles alors
après je ne sais pas qui quoi comment
mais globalement voilà il ya et c'est
l'horreur concrètement comment on fait
c'est à dire que vous êtes d'accord mais
c'est pour bientôt team est ce que
poutine veut arrêter à ce que vous dites
vous dit les accords de minsk mais en
fait le cessez le feu mais sauf que le
peuple ukrainien est souverain il ya 44
millions de personnes on égrène qu'ils
veulent qui ont voté pour dsk 73 % au
deuxième tour et ils veulent pas être
sous le joug de poutine donc comment on
fait on leur dit ah bah non c'est comme
ça voyez ce que je veux dire donc
comment elle se laissait alors moi je
fais pas de politique mais à titre
personnel ce que je pense c'est il faut
oeuvrer pour la diplomatie réécouter
védrine et de villepin qui se sont
exprimés sur la question ils sont
beaucoup plus informés que moi remettre
sur le tour de la table des gens qui qui
qui tente de de trouver des solutions ce
n'est pas acceptable
je suis d'accord et je le dis mais
comment faire il faut réécouter les
spécialistes hubert védrine est un
spécialiste de villepin est un
spécialiste on ans renaud girard qui est
un spécialiste c'est le peuple ukrainien
il est spécialiste aussi de son destin
oui mais vous voyez bien y venir ainsi
vote juste dont windows 7 bien ici j'y
vais aller vers l'automne l'eau pour les
intéressés il faut il faut faire marcher
la diplomatie parce que vous savez ça le
problème de la diplomatie
ne fonctionne qu
les canons gronde mais de deux stations
de la diplomatie n'a jamais fonctionné
avec poutine il
a jamais voulu
sûrement vous donner ce que google ce qu
est ce que le problème entre les
ukrainiens et l'ukrainien
excusez moi mais si on n'avait pas eu de
villepin voyez bien que la diplomatie
paris mais deux doigts par les oiseaux
de cotation on est hors sujet est-ce que
vous condamner l'intervention russe à
l'ukraine écoutez j'ai condamné les
gouvernés
évidemment et je conte et je condamne
les combats condamne tout bombardement
et footing pour auch encore par dean
était un dictateur ou pas votre avis
c'est un régime autoritaire oui ok car
l'an vous avez parlé de l'américaine qui
était pointé comme ministre dans le
gouvernement ukrainien est ce que vous
trouvez normal qu'en 2004 poutine vient
en ukraine dans un pays souverain pour
le proposer leur peur leur président
ianoukovitch il est dit voilà vous devez
élire sept personnes et moi président
d'un pays voisin je vous je vous combien
je vous amène cette personne elise et là
je ne trouve rien mal dans le monde qui
accueille aujourd'hui il ya très peu de
choses que je trouve normal alors non
non vous ne pouvez pas vous le dit pas
mais parce qu'on se donne des interviews
les trompe mais vous avez voce de la
belge avait vos blogs maintenant je suis
obligé d'en monter ok je vais pas vous
être end pascal le gasc ce ne sont pas
les ukrainiens qui se bat contre
l'ukraine ce sont les russes ce sont les
russes
alors il guigne c'est un officier du fsb
le dit le ministre de la défense de
donetsk c'est un officier et sbs que
1996 à damien à 2300 officiers de pilc
2014 qui ont entraîné les instructeurs
américains ça c'est sûr mais l'état
russe d'azov et les autres écuries
je vous dis il ya les russes et les
américains mais on pense qu il faut
qu'on dise il faut qu'on qu'il serait
jamais un cadeau réalisation sur moi
j'ai une question sur bocsa on a vu on a
vu les images le monde est saisi
d'effroi de l'horreur à bout de chat il
ya les organisations humanitaire human
right watch qui dit il ya des crimes de
guerre apparent dans les zones
contrôlées par les russes comme bocsa et
vous vous dites tout à l'heure il faudra
expertise et ça pendant des années il
faudra voir c'est pas nous c'est la
méchante et de timisoara c'est moi
jusqu'à accuser me sucer moi je suis en
bac de ces enquêtes ça vous déplaît mais
c'est la réalité
abuja la responsabilité russe c'est cela
qui est choquant en sorbonne lgt ce
n'est pas absolument parce que si vous
avez des il faudra des années pour
savoir c'est le savez c'est là où vous
continuez à des douaniers monsieur
pourtant il est raciste dans les lignes
de tourner avec ce que je vous dis en
période de guerre les mensonges et les
propagandes et les rumeurs sont ce qu'il
ya de plus nuisibles donc le massacre de
boue de chasse est une rumeur et je ne
le nie pas geneviève
et vous reconnaissez les faits ou des
rues sont dits plus donc je préfère ne
pas vous répondre ah bah voilà alors est
ce que veut un dernier mot à dire ce
qu'on doit rendre l'antenne
j'espère que je suis navré pour
l'ensemble des ukrainiens d'accord ce
qui se passe c'est désastreux aucune
guerre n'est propre
moi j'ai craint aucune qui est toutes
les guerres sont une boucherie je les
condamne et tout mon travail que ce soit
du haut karabagh et si
jusqu'à la russie jusqu'au don basse
jusqu'au yémen jusqu'à la libye je
passerais mon temps à dénoncer les
exactions je suis contre j'ai toujours
été aux cupr auch des civils je suis un
peu je me bats depuis toujours avec les
premiers gilet jaune pas ceux qui sont
allés sur les champs elysées manifester
etc et détruire
les gens ne sont pas des choses
explique moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est ce
et les civils uniquement les civils
voilà parce que pendant que tout le
monde se bat là et bien les jet-setteurs
ceux qui ont de l'argent ils sont partis
un tout ce qu'ils aient tous les matins
guerre ils sont là demain quand c'est
nous tous